[Musique]
noëlle bréham bonjour bonjour ironique
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur le plateau de tv fil 78 pour un vip
qui vous est consacré on va parler de
vous de votre nouvelle émission est de
plein de choses très intéressantes
merci de m'avoir invité c'est un grand
plaisir on s'était déjà bien amusé une
fois sur une barque et sous une serre au
château voilà parce qu'on avait évoqué
justement une émission sur france inter
qui s'appelle silence ça pousse
n'importe quoi qui s'appelle même les
petits bateaux excusez moi et oui on
s'était mis sur un bateau pour évoquer
les petits bateaux mais non non pas du
tout et n'importe quoi puisque à
l'époque je faisais aussi s'élance et
trouve ça que je mélange pas du tout
dame est justement les petits bateaux ça
dure toujours et encore oui la fête au
vogue et bien quel est le principe de
cette émission des enfants posent des
questions et des savants répondent
qu'ils sont pas forcément des questions
bébé mais c'est quand même posé par des
enfants et quand le savant entend une
voix d'enfant il parle simplement
haineux jargonne pas il donc c'est une
émission pour vous et moi c'est quand
même bloqué entre le journal et le
masque et la plume qui sont des
émissions pour adultes le dimanche soir
le dimanche soir sur france inter à
19h30
mais les questions sont posées par des
enfants donc le savant automatiquement
par le simplement jay audible voilà et
c'est génial ça l'idée en fait et puis
deuxième chose c'est que les enfants aux
poser des questions que nous on
n'oserait pas posée parce qu'on a peur
de pas avoir l'air malin n'a peur de pas
avoir l'air cultivées en absence avait
des jambes la peur que eux n'ont pas
encore sur tout téléphone on y voit pas
est ressassé c'est très très pertinent
ce que vous dites parce qu'au début j'ai
j'allais les chalets les interviewés
avec un vrai avec un agra aux déchets
nous et
il était intimidé alors que là c'est
bravo véronique sont tout seuls ils
peuvent ne pas dire leur nom et c sont
peinards et peuvent recommencer cet
anonyme et quand un enfant dit j'ai
l'impression que mes parents préfèrent
mon frère il ne dirait pas en public ils
le disent tous seuls ouais alors ça ça
dure encore et encore pour l'avènement
bonheur ensuite sinon ça pousse en fait
c'était une émission de télévision
ouais vous avez co animer cette émission
pendant 13 ans avec stéphane marc hé oui
inhibition de jardinage et c'est de là
que les gens je pense connaître votre
tête si je peux dire alors c'est de là
qu'ils connaissent ma tête je veux te
voir et m'avoir je fais déjà un peu
télévision avant mais silence ça pousse
a bien marché c'est vrai il marche
toujours très bien je vous la recommande
chaudement
et puis france à terme a proposé une
quotidienne autre chose j'ai quitté mon
stéphane marie cher rupture pour aller
sur l'indirect voilà mais c'est un grand
et bon souvenir d'accord donc vous avez
ce kit et stéphane marie pour l'émission
qui passait l'année dernière la saison
dernière qui était une émission de libre
antenne
ouais ce qui était assez commun il ya
longtemps il qui n'existait plus on est
d'accord la france inter a vu la libre
antenne avec la fameuse macha béranger
et puis voilà y'a plus depuis des années
de libre antenne et puis c'est est
revenu avec des comptes avec des
auditeurs qui moi me disait des choses
qui me passionnait et puis
bon les les méandres et les mystères de
la programmation elle s'est arrêtée
d'accord j'étais désolé parce que je l'
ai adoré cette émission et puis en même
temps c'est pas mal dans sa vie privée
d'avoir ces soirées donc oui il y avait
du pour et du contre
voilà toute façon j'ai pas le choix donc
là voilà je les prie avec joie et là
j'ai complètement oublié mais en fait
vous êtes là aussi parce que vous étiez
viennoise ah oui c'est ça notre client à
la base on s'est rencontré sur le marché
de versailles vient quelques temps vous
avez fait toute votre scolarité à
versailles et vous habitez toujours les
yvelines voilà voilà ça c'est dit et
pour la joie de we7 donne la joie de
vous recevoir
donc cette émission de libre antenne
terminé n'en parlons plus pour une
nouvelle émission qui a démarré en
septembre qui s'appelle cette fois ci un
état d'esprit
voilà voilà alors qu est ce que c est à
découvrir à leur état d'esprit c'est une
émission 2 sagesse qui a le cas oui ça
fait grand beau mais c'est tout simple
en fête qui a lieu le soir à 22h donc
sur france inter et c'était un horaire
où nous sommes tranquilles
ça fait à peu près une heure pour parler
tranquillement avec un artiste
scientifique un philosophe ou ou
quelqu'un comme vous et moi qui vit tout
simplement mais à qui je demande quelle
quelle est sa vie intérieure ce qu'à son
avis on est venu faire sur cette terre
comme ya un manque carrément com -
est-ce qu'on peut faire pour que ça se
passe le mieux le mieux possible
il ya des gens dont c'est la profession
et des gens dont ce n'est pas la
profession on peut vendre des choux
fleurs et avoir un avis très intéressant
sur ce qu'on est venu faire sur cette
terre donc cette émission qui passe le
dimanche soir à 22h
elle est très intime finalement vous
avez un rapport très intime avec votre
invité parce que vous lui posez des ce
que j'ai envie d'appeler des vraies
questions
on est dans l'authentiqué on est dans la
profondeur on est on est dans l'ain d'un
type j'ai déjà dit mais on est aussi
dans la sincérité mais c'est intéressant
ce que vous dites véronique on est dans
l'ain team de l'ain team je sais pas si
vous avez ça dans votre vie
moi j'ai des amis dont je sais beaucoup
de choses sur la vie privée même parfois
des dvd des détails sur la vie sexuelle
disons c'est vrai que des copines qui se
lâche et je ne sais rien sur ce à quoi
ils croient est ce qu'elle croit qu'il
ya une vie après la mort au pain et ce
qu'elle croit en dieu au pain et ce
qu'elle croit en un mystère sur la
création du monde pas et met jamais
j'oserais leur demander oui alors que l
vous diront le film de leurs ébats
minute par minute ce qui ne porte pas de
jugement mais il ya du déballage de la
team dans un domaine est en revanche
jamais sacré top secret merci dans un
autre après il suffirait de poser des
questions vous faites à vos invités
c'est pas si facile bon oui moi j'ai
parfois j'ai l'impression d'être
discrètes parfois chez et puis les gens
vont peut-être se sont jamais posé la
question
c'est un domaine qu'on n'aborde pas
alors qu'il ya des parutions il ya des
magazines et des livres là dessus qu'ils
ont bien et donc par le ca intéresse les
gens bien sûr république pour ce qu'on
appelle le spirituel on fait moins voilà
voilà la discussion j'avais envie de
dire cette émission sera spirituel ou ne
sera pas ouais pour plagier je sais plus
malraux et voilà et comme on vous
choisissez justement vous invitez
comment elle savoir s'ils sont ou non
dans le sérieux dans l'eau net dans le
sincère ou est et savoir que ce que ce
ne sont pas des chats l'entente dès lors
c'est l'âge véronique c'est l'âge c'est
à dire que c'est à force de
de lire d'écouter de et ben on finit par
arriver à trier un petit peu le je peux
me tromper mais on veut on comprend tout
de suite si ainsi quelqu'un est un doux
dingue
si les barres et parce que c'est quand
même je suis pas loin du précipice mais
c'est sa cr caval'art m'aviez dit le
jazz sur des sables mouvants oui c'est
quand même des sujets délicats
il y avait aussi pour ça que peut
laisser votre lettre il ya beaucoup de
branne zinc voilà il faut pas en plus
c'est mais par exemple quand j'ai reçu
françoise hardy ça fait très longtemps
qu'on sait que françoise hardy est folle
non pas du tout à fait raisonnable
complètement elle est même assez assez
austère voile avez vous invité cette
chanteuse alors j'ai invité cette
chanteuse parce qu'elle a écrit un livre
où elle parle de plusieurs ses deux
derniers livres le dernier parle de sa
maladie elle est passée près du bord et
elles se demandent pourquoi finalement
elle est encore là qu'il a rattrapé par
les cheveux c'est ton c'est donc une
belle question de vraies questions et
elle croit un mystère de la vie elle
croit qu'on est venu sur cette terre
pour s'améliorer et convient et qu'on
revient elle croit leurs incarnations
alors je sais pas si c'est vraiment la
réincarnation à laquelle elle croit je
veux pas mettre d'étiquette sur ses
croyances parce que ça c'est à elle de
le faire mais je crois une mission elle
croit un mystère un mystère d'accord
alors on va parler de l'avenir
que voyez vous demain alors lavaud
montchamp invité alors clavier compris
mes prochains invités sont absolument
passionnant il ya un homme qui va venir
parler des arts puisqu'on parle de
bizarre mais les arbres sont des gens
comme les autres
les arbres on en a besoin on a besoin
physiquement on peut leur parler ils
vous il vous aide dans la dans la
médecine chinoise ils sont très
importants voilà d'accord on va parler
et des mères les mamans kabyle mais
carbone est une historienne qui a écrit
un livre sur les mers des grands hommes
décoiffante d'ailleurs est ce que les
femmes finalement sont aussi intéressés
aussi des mères et ont aussi des mères
noël et mères les mamans les arbres j'ai
reçus philippe jamet quitte un
psychiatre qui dit des choses
passionnantes mais est-ce que génial
excusez moi c'est que avec les moyens
modernes on peut réécouter
voilà c'est ça c'est un grand bonheur
donc en replay on peut se sont choisis
sont invités à françoise hardy luc ferry
recchi emmanuel schalit ferrer très
drôle le fait rire et drôle
y en a marre de la spiritualité des
bondieuseries à la de la bienveillance
vocation est d'ailleurs voit plein de
marde la bienveillance avec soi même
enfin bon vous tournez il et il est
libre lille et tonique la de l'énergie
libre et disent qu'ils en vivent ou
l'écouté avec bienveillance je trouvais
way est pas que lui mais en général avec
patience et bienveillant c'est vraiment
un régal
bah je partage pas forcément ce qu'il
dit mais j'invite pas que des gens qui
sont d'accord avec moi ça chez les
messieurs voilà et mais il est
intelligent il mérite d'être entendu
écouté et dites moi votre petite
madeleine de pouce dans les yvelines
c'est quoi on change aussi haut mais
vous j'adore les yvelines cesser les
hôtels et voudra peuvent pas imaginer
alors versailles c'est beau magnifique
un petit endroit secret mais un petit
endroit secret je vous le dirais
sûrement pas pour ce récit les secrets
existe si les secrets c'est paraissait
pas pourrait dit on dit quand même un
petit alors un petit endroit secret à
pied en vélo ou à cheval
moi je les fais à pied à vélo et à
cheval aulas et par la petite porte de
maintenant au fond au fond du fond quand
vous allez tout au fond du grand canal
lacroix ya une grille qui mène vers la
ferme de gally vers l'aéroport de st
signal vers l'ouest disent on pourrait
bien booster alors êtes vous allé vers
l'ouest vous allez vers la normandie
vous allez vers le havre vers la mer là
vous sortez par cette petite porte qui
est petit et ça c'est assez joli
et vous continuez vers l'est et doit
être inhumé vers l'ouest et là on
traverse on arrive et on traverse la
plaine de versailles on longe le rue de
gally
on arrive vers villepreux on va jusqu'où
vos forces vos portes et puis demi tour
ou une espèce de boucle parce qu'il ya
plusieurs itinéraires possibles mais on
est à une demi heure de paris on a
l'impression qu'on a fait 500 km et en
revient par cette petite porte de
versailles qui est la petite porte de
maintenant et on revient au bout du
grand canal et puis on voit un petit peu
les les jardins de baraton les jardins
du trianon là on peut attacher son
cheval ou attention la tâche qu'il aille
pas manger les fleurs de bach attention
vous allez l'entendre et à poser son
vélo posé son sac et son cheval et
pique-niqué là mais c'est juste un
bonheur quoi
ok merci pour ce cadeau noël et à très
vite merci véronique à dimanche soir il
ya dimanche matin au marché et à
dimanche soir 22 heures sur france inter
voilà dans le poste
ciao ciao
[Musique]